hey I'm Sarah weinshank I'm here to
answer the internet if a guy matches
with his best friend's sister on Tinder
should he pursue it it depends whether
or not the sister's hot if she's hot
[__] yeah but not worth ruining your
friendship if she's not hot
can't ruin your friendship with a butter
face if the girls hot the brother can't
be mad he knows what his genetics did
what's the worst thing you've gotten
thrown out of a bar for uh taking my
ex-boyfriend's wallet out of the back of
his pocket while I was in college and
refusing to give it back then I was
carried out of the bar screaming
I wanted attention
was he like yo this girl stole my wallet
like get her out he was causing a scene
oh I was causing a scene I was also
dressed in it the theme of the party was
Grandpa's and gold diggers and I was in
an outfit that said that was gold and a
shirt that said now I ain't saying I'm a
gold digger and then I took his wallet
it was just part I just committed to the
[__] yeah is jerking off to webcam
girls cheating now dude you could Jerk
it to whoever you want especially if
it's like if there's a screen between
you that's fine what if it what if it
was not a wet it was just another girl
I don't I don't mind jerk off to whoever
the [__] you want it's actually easier
for me if you come before we even hang
out
[Music]
I'm on the phone
I'm phone sex with each other his ex is
different than a webcam girl or just
watching porn if it's with his ex then
that's low-key cheating what about it
Thai key cheaters x it's not a sex
worker it's not an ex it's just like a
random girl
I don't really care
cool guys you should date Sarah yeah
hell yeah would you have sex with a dead
person for five minutes if you'd get
your laundry done and folded magically
for the rest of your life usually with
the dick be hard usually it's more like
a guy to a girl but yeah like just say
there's some rigor mortis and you can
just hop up on time so you're saying
it's a rigor mortis dick and then I
never have to do my laundry again just
for five minutes yes that's longer than
you think
what if I come on the [__] dead guys
[Laughter]
I mean if I could get my laundry done
and Matt folded magically for the rest
of my life I'd hop on a dead dick for
five minutes that's the question yeah
there you go if everybody knew
I wouldn't want anyone to know that I
[__] a dead person for five minutes to
have my laundry done absolutely not that
changes everything it's gonna be My
Little Secret
if you could have an endless supply of
anything what would it be dick
[Laughter]
for real there's so much all I hear
about is that there's so much bad dick
out there I guess money money and dicks
money doesn't count because that's like
stupid makeup and dick
[Laughter]
that's really the name of the podcast
makeup and dick
hell yeah how far are you willing to
drive for sex not that far it also
depends how horny I am yeah do you know
what I mean I think the whiter I am the
less I'm less far I'm going to drive
before you ever really drive for sex you
should just come and see if I if you
jerk off and then you still want to go
then you go okay yeah pretty much you
should do that before you make any
decision come and then if you still want
to make that decision then you do it
yeah I'm a different person no I am a
different person after I come way nicer
way less of a [__] after I come of
course everybody is but usually it's a
guy driving for sex but you know girls
like I feel like if I was a girl I'd be
like I don't drive anyone for sex people
they come here yeah that's what I think
so too unless I was really horny and the
dick was really good and I'd already
tested it and I knew the product before
doing the drive
then so let's say it's like Primo
yeah yeah just 20. so you're not it's
basically zero yeah if you could pick a
fake name what would it be amethyst
why did you have that was amethyst a
real name no it's a stone yeah and I'm a
hippie [__] it was the first thing that
came to my mind
yeah I've been sitting on Amethyst for
some while I've been waiting for
somebody to ask me this I feel like a
lot of girls always have like oh that's
my drunk Alter Ego or some [__] like
that yeah you know yeah I'm like I'm
amethyst am I a stripper
yeah
yeah this is something that makes you
automatically swipe right on Tinder
tattoos hate to say it out loud I like a
tattoo oh right is good obviously like
you like right you like it I like I like
Inked men what are they good like a
sleeve like sleeve face text no face
tats I'm out neck tatts neck tatts I'm
open to a tastefulness a tasteful sleeve
makes me swipe right what about like uh
Ben Affleck [__] Phoenix across the
back
no Ben Affleck's Phoenix across the back
is a red flag it has to be a well done
sleeve it can't be like a tiger on your
chest yeah Ben Affleck doesn't do it for
me
I think that's incorrect I think you're
wrong
do you guys want to [__] Ben Affleck I
think you get in a room with Ben Affleck
and he [__] you I think you're you
might be right and then JLo [__]
murders me how much money would it take
for you to streak on the field at an NFL
game 100K a hundred I think you would do
it or less
I think I'm gonna put like 25k cash
right now 50K
yeah probably like let's be honest
I'm trying not to sound like a complete
loser poor [__] so that's why I said a
hundred thousand but I would definitely
do it for 25
000. I might even do it for 15. should
you lock a dog out of the room when
you're having sex yeah
but the problem is that my dog just
cries and cries and cries and cries by
the door that's what makes me come
yeah but I don't I don't want my dog in
the room while I'm [__]
really yeah I know it's like having a
[__] in the room that's not even a human
I don't want an animal [__] in the room
get into it you like that dog oh yeah
yeah yeah exactly
thank you for watching Anthony please
subscribe to the channel comment below
on all the celebrities you'd like to see
and make sure you hit the Bell to get
notifications when new episodes come out